c'est l'heure maintenant notre second
débat dans ce sens public comme nous le
faisons régulièrement depuis le début de
la saison c'était dans la campagne
présidentielle et aussi dans ces
législatives nous propose un comparatif
de programme aujourd'hui zoom sur les
propositions économiques de la nuque et
d'ensemble et deux coalitions qui se
disputent la majorité absolue à
l'assemblée sandra
smic à 1500 euros net retour de la
retraite à 60 ans baisse de la tva sur
les produits de première nécessité
recrutement de fonctionnaires ce sont
quelques-unes des propositions de la
nuque qui affirme que son programme est
l'un des seuls chiffres et
250 milliards d'euros financée entre
autres par une hausse des impôts pour
les ménages les plus aisés et
l'augmentation des droits de succession
un programme économique jugé dangereux
pour la majorité présidentielle
j'ai peur pour mon pays le programme
économique de jean-luc mélenchon il
n'est pas une appli câble parce qu'on
aurait des dogmes il est inapplicable
parce qu as-tu partir du moment où ils
commenceraient à être peut-être
appliquer les entreprises de notre pays
ferait faillite si ed a failli de macin
sélect du chômage massif c'est du
chômage massif personne ne sort plus
riches de cette affaire c'est un immense
mensonge que jean luc mélenchon propose
aux français emmanuel macron a promis 15
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts
sur le quinquennat la suppression de la
redevance audiovisuelle et une baisse de
l'impôt sur les successions ces
réductions des prélèvements serait
financé par des économies mais la nuque
accuse emmanuel macron de vouloir
augmenter sans le dire la tva pour
financer ces réformes emmanuel macron
s'est engagé auprès de la commission
européenne même si le document assure le
pacte de stabilité n'a pas été
finalement envoyé mais
il s'est engagé à ramener les déficits
publics à 3% du pib en fin de
quinquennat donc à l'horizon 2027
comment vont-ils faire pour
réduire les dépenses publiques de 81
milliards d'euros ce qui serait une
saignée comme on en a jamais connu mais
là on aimerait avoir des réponses
le gouvernement affirme qu'il n'ya pas
de programme caché ni de non dit que
l'objectif est bien de réduire les
déficits à 3% d'ici 2027 mais sans
augmentation de la tva
le second débat de ce sens public je
vous présente mes invités sabine iceman
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes économiste
maître de conférences à l'université
paris cité vous avez signé l'appel de
dizaines d'économistes en faveur du
programme de la nuque pour ces
législatives j'accueille également eric
delannoy bonjour bonjour bonsoir
économiste brillant et fondateur du
cabinet tenzing soutien d' emmanuel
macron xavier timbeau bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes directeur de l'efs c'est
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques et alors si j'ai bien
compris à ses critiques vis-à-vis des
deux programmes en tout cas vous nous
expliquerez sa matthieu croissandeau
litoralis politique est toujours à mes
côtés si on est fait de différencier
tiens j'ai commencé comme ça sabrina
eastman cox et quelle est pour vous la
principale différence entre le programme
économique de la dupe et celui
d'ensemble partie de la majorité
présentielle la coalition présidentielle
d'un côté on a un programme qui
favorise davantage les grandes firmes
multinationales et les plus fortunés et
qui négligent les plus modestes et d'un
autre côté on a un programme qui est
porteur d'espoir en termes de transition
sociale écologique et qui vise à
diminuer les inégalités économiques et
sociales et qui visent véritablement à
prendre en compte l'urgence écologique
notamment dans ce pays donc vous avez
spécifié que la tribune avait été signé
par des dizaines d'économistes elle a
été signée par plus de 170 économistes
avec un spectre extrêmement large dont
qui va de
de piketty à kg a en effet eric baer des
économistes atterrés donc on a inscrit
être extrêmement large qui ont signé et
qui considère que le programme en tout
cas qui est porté par cette coalition
puisque cette unité à gauche on
attendait depuis très très longtemps
elle est porteuse d'espoir et notamment
pour les plus modestes et notamment en
termes d'inégalités pour les services
publics qui ont été énormément fragilisé
durant ce quinquennat oui on verra aussi
qu'il ya eu d'autres tribus notamment
une signée par le nobel d'économie jean
denis jean tirole en iran on y reviendra
tout à l'heure et eric delannoy
finalement la principale pierre que les
économistes atterrés où les économistes
qui soutiennent jean luc mélenchon
mettre dans le jardin est mal macron
c'est toujours un peu président des
riches et et l'absence de propositions
en matière de justice sociale est-ce que
s qui madaule macro est toujours le
président des riches les marques comme
ça ma le président des riches qui est le
premier à avoir fait le 0 reste à charge
pour les frais de santé qui a revalorisé
alors je vais parler avant l'inflation
ont effectivement décidé des mesures
complémentaires qui a revalorisé tous
les minima sociaux comme il n'avait pas
été fait depuis très longtemps qui a
augmenté l'emploi des jeunes comme ils
avaient fêté depuis 20 ans qui a mis
emploi moi je peux justice pour pour
sortir de ce débat un peu stérile de
riches ou parrish toujours le spectre de
la loi pacte la loi pacte peu de gens la
connaissent mais quand on la connaît ça
veut dire qu'on s'intéresse vraiment à
la politique puisque c'est une loi qui a
été votée en 2019
qu'on me dise qu'il ne voit pas que ce
soit une once de gauche ou de droite moi
j'en serais incapable dans la loi pas qu
il ya beaucoup de dispositions qui
simplifie la vie des entreprises à ce
titre là ce serait peut-être une oie de
droite et puis il ya des dispositions
qui font en sorte de redéfinir le rôle
de l'entreprise ou dans le social
environnemental va très loin ce site
émission raison d'être et c est qui
bouge considérablement les lignes est ce
que c'est de droite est ce que c'est de
gauche en fait ça m'intéresse pas ce que
je vois c'est des preuves c'est ce qui a
été fait et donc j'ai moi même travaillé
je peux vous le dire sur le programme
d'économie sociale et solidaire d'une
programme macro et je peux vous dire
qu'il est conséquent d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que dans le flou
d'incantation qu'on peut lire sur le
programme de lannux
on va combattre les crises comme on n'en
sait rien mais on va combattre
l'illettrisme il ya un ensemble de
petites mesures qu'on retrouve dans
notre programme donc ça on ne dit jamais
mais c'est assez assez intéressant
notamment la révision du code du code
des marchés publics pour favoriser les
entreprises donc enfin faut sortir de
ces faux débats c'est pour les riches il
est vrai que on y reviendra peut-être il
ya aussi peut-être un problème de
méthode et ceux de ce qu'on affiche
xavier timbeau comment vous si vous
cherchez à comparer ou peut-être
apporter un jouet un peu général sur les
deux programmes je disais aucun ne
trouve vraiment grâce à vos yeux est ce
que c'est vrai ou est-ce que je
caricature un peu c'est pas que c'est
pas ben je vais pas me permettre de dire
qu'aucun ne trouve grâce à mes yeux
c'est mal c'est pas le point il faut
bien voir qu'on est dans une campagne et
dans une campagne les programmes c'est
une série de promesses donc après il ya
deux attitudes soit on les prend au pied
de la lettre et
on peut être à ce moment là extrêmement
critique parce que il ya toujours des
choses qui sont
silencieuses omise pas réaliste pas
pragmatique dans un programme ont des
deux côtés des deux côtés et on pourra
en parler parce qu'il ya quand même des
choses intéressantes des deux côtés et
puis après on peut essayer de regarder
le souffle l'esprit
de du programme donc voilà je pense que
de ce point de vue là le programme de la
nuque et encore une fois je vais pas à
porter un jugement parce que je suis pas
là pour ça mais il faut reconnaître que
il a
apporté des réponses un somme de
questions que se posent des gens sur les
inégalités en disco qui est très
volontariste sur la transition
environnementale
même si c'est quand même enfin si ça va
jusqu'à
1 euros 40
le litre
de gasoil c'est ça si je me sens il me
trouvais alors ça c'est la position du
pouvoir d'achat ils s'affublent
contradictions justement enfin ou des
grosse contradiction qu'on peut trouver
dans le programme et il ya effectivement
d'un côté un discours très aventureux
sur l'écologiste et puis aussi l'idée
qu'il faut relancer l'économie
qui va falloir dépenser beaucoup et donc
et que ça ça va produire de l'activité
qui va venir financer ses dépenses et
donc là on est dans une logique qui est
plutôt quand même
productiviste ou deux gars qui
recherchent la croissance voilà donc on
peut
rester un peu dubitatif en fait sûr mais
dans ce programme au fond qu'est-ce
qu'il faut que gens retiennent c'est à
dire si jamais demain
cela n'eut pt au pouvoir si jean luc
mélenchon était premier ministre qu'est
ce qui serait fait exactement parce que
on sait bien que l'exercice du pouvoir
c'est à la fois d'un côté ce qu'on a
promis mais c'est aussi ce qu'on peut
faire et c'est ce qu'on est en position
de faire d'accord alors on y reviendra
et on va rentrer dans les détails dont
vous trouvez évidemment explicite et
mathieu quelque chose qui est absent et
c'est remarquable je trouve remarquable
sens a remarqué dans les airs est
probable c'est que la lutte contre le
chômage en tant que tel a dit spies a
disparu parce que mécaniquement alors
est ce que c'est un truc de riches ou de
pauvres tout cas le chômage a quand même
considérablement baisser le taux de
chômage pendant pendant son quinquennat
et le président et sa majorité n'en sont
pas remercié par la france est
exactement de la même façon que lionel
jospin qui était notre premier ministre
avoir fait considérablement baisser le
chômage
tant qu'ils occupaient à matignon n'a
pas été reversées par les français de
l'élection euros cc c'est fou parce que
quand ça ne va pas c'est le 1d premier
item des français et des premiers des
premières revendications et des
premières propositions et quand ça va
mieux évidemment ces niveaux de logis
remet ça c'est assez intéressant ce que
vous dites parce que ça a effectivement
été longtemps une mythologie de la
politique en france c'est à dire celui
qu on va faire baisser le cheval à celui
qui ne fait pas baisser le chômage avant
d'être de se présenter aux élections il
est sûr de perdre et puis en fait et du
coup ça a mis quand même la baisse du
chômage au centre des politiques la
baisse du chômage qu'on aa qu'on a vu
c'est aussi une baisse du chômage qui a
été obtenu par un certain nombre de
réformes de flexibilisation du marché du
travail dessus
et donc du coup c'est peut-être aussi
pour ça que pour les français c'est
apparaît pas comme quelque chose d'aussi
formidable peut-être ça tue un peu le
débat parce que l'indicateur chômage
après la situation s'améliore par
ailleurs je ne connais pas tout n'est
pas noir tout n'est pas blanc mais
disons ça ça fait passer la question du
chômage ou second plan
sans pour autant provoquer une forêt en
se disant ben voilà on est aujourd'hui
dans un marché du travail où n'importe
qui trouvent un emploi aussi vite qu'il
veut quand on sait que ça c'est pas bien
et ses nerfs sur les chiffres du chômage
oui vous êtes chez pas jean-luc
mélenchon les remet en cause dont
14 sont sont discutables souvent il est
important de prendre une multitude
d'indicateurs et là si on regarde les
chiffres de pôle emploi à côté du taux
de chômage au sens du bit est donc en
effet en nette baisse à une baisse de la
catégorie à c'est-à-dire de ceux qui
sont sans aucune activité mais face au
jeu suivant contre 115 jours depuis
depuis des années donc vous il va pas
changer la ville 14
là on prend en compte également d'autres
indicateurs il ya d'autres indicateurs
qui sont importants à prendre en compte
on a l'ensemble des demandeurs d'emploi
mais surtout on a les catégories b et c
pôle emploi et les catégories b et c de
pôle emploi est bien de huy 2016 2017 on
a plus de 2 millions catégories b et c
pôle emploi donc ce sont des gens qui
ont des contrats courts des contrats à
temps partiel qui sont en contrat avec
des conditions de travail dégradées qui
recherchent un autre emploi et c'est un
vrai révélateur de la situation sur
notre marché du travail c'est pour ça
que même si on a une baisse du taux de
chômage au sens du bit et et bien
derrière cela on a une partie de la
population qui n'est pas satisfait de
son emploi avec des mauvaises conditions
de travail des mauvaises conditions
d'emploi et en cela c'est pas seulement
la question du plein emploi en tant
qu'indicateur quantitatif qui est
important c'est également la question du
plein emploi en termes d'indicateurs
qualitatifs quel emploi on veut
également pour nos travailleurs en
france est ce qu'on veut en emplois de
qualité avec des conditions de travail
dignes avec des salaires dignes ou est
ce qu'on veut des emplois au rabais des
petites des petits travaux avec quelques
heures de travail au plein emploi
mais effectivement travailleurs avec des
petites heures de travail donné la
parole à eric delannoy là-dessus pardon
de vous interrompre et on retombe
effectivement sur la question du du sens
d'un métier il ya eu manque que 7 à 8000
chauffeur de cas on en a parlé dans
cette émission on en parlait juste avant
il manque 60 mille infirmiers 230 250
mille personnes pour le secteur chr café
hôtellerie et restauration en bref sur
la réalité ou des chiffres en
trompe-l'oeil qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cela mais en fait c'est
toujours pareil j'aimais bien la
comparaison qui rompt je suis toujours
les mêmes les mêmes chiffres et tout à
coup quand les chiffres là s'améliore
tout à coup il faut changer d'indicateur
c'est toujours très intéressant
néanmoins quand on multiplie les
indicateurs il a quand même un
indicateur qu'il faut regarder c'est le
taux d'emploi le taux d'emploi c'est à
dire les noms de personnes qui ont été
mis au travail n'a jamais été aussi
élevé depuis 25 ans d'accord on parle de
cul de qualitatif je suis assez d'accord
que sur la partie qualitative notamment
sur les nouveaux emplois dans la
logistique il ya un sujet néanmoins il
ya une remise au travail d'un ensemble
de de deux personnes n'ont pas des
emplois précaires ça c'est totalement
faux puisque là encore le nombre de cdi
n'a jamais été aussi élevé depuis 25 ans
donc donc quand on parle du taux
d'emploi et quand tu parles du nombre de
cdi on est sur des chiffres qui sont
extrêmement forts mis en garde internet
trimestre dernier incident prime à 2020
dans mais oui
juste les dernières
dans quel s façonner une baisse des
embauches donc on est un signe qui vient
des cochons qui stagne à deux derniers
frimas nouvelle regarder à l'aune d'une
première tic économique globale et mais
c'est incroyable de regarder les
chiffres du dernier trimestre contre moi
je vous parle d'une évolution plus en
moi je vous parle
est une fausse bonne mais moi je vous
parle une évolution depuis 2010 est et
depuis 2010 est l'emploi des jeunes
notamment n'a jamais été aussi favorable
lors je sais que monsieur mélenchon dit
que l'apprentissage c'est pas de
l'emploi mais c'est faux donc à mon beau
sapin puisqu'on compte un tout petit mot
de réponse là dessus et on change de
thème si vous voulez répondre non ce qui
en l'occurrence depuis depuis le début
2022 on a en effet des signaux
macroéconomiques et dessiné en termes
d'emploi qui montre qu'il y a
certainement un retournement en termes
du marché du travail on a un certain
nombre d'indicateurs on a les
déclarations d'embauché qui qui n'ont
pas augmenté de la même manière on a un
repli de l'emploi intérimaire on sait
bien que dès qu'on a un retournement de
la conjoncture économique les premiers
emplois qui se retourne c'est notamment
l'emploi intérimaire donc en effet on
peut tout à fait sortir en terme de
campagne électorale qu'on va arriver non
lien vers le plein emploi et qu'on va
vers le plein emploi aujourd'hui ce cas
les indicateurs macro économiques
montrent qu'on n'y va pas on a entendu
les arguments aux uns et aux autres là
dessus mathieu oublier revenir sur ce
qu'est la polémique de cet entre deux
tours sur le front
des programmes d'économies que la sphère
des des 80 milliards on va écouter
d'abord jean luc mélenchon qui était
taillée en meeting à toulouse si vous
voulez réduire le déficit du budget de
l'état à 3% alors qu'il est à six et
demi ça veut dire que vous devez
économiser retirer ou apporter dans le
budget 80 milliards oui ou non alors où
allez vous trouver ses 80 milliards
comme dans le même temps vous dit vous
allez augmenter le nombre de lits
d'hôpitaux que vous allez augmenter les
salaires que vous allez recruter
davantage d'enseignants et pas seulement
les deux unions au hasard dans la rue et
cetera et cetera à quel moment mentez
vous quand vous écrivez à la commission
ou quand vous parlez aux français alors
on l'a évoqué mais rapidement dans le
sujet d'ouverture de ce débat mathieu
d'où vient ce serait bien de l'objectif
de la trajectoire des finances publiques
nous m'ont dit que la france comme tous
les états membres de l'union européenne
on voit à la commission pour dire un peu
ou comment vont se passer les années à
venir et où vont se situer les finances
publiques l'exécutif prévoit ead a prévu
de ramener le déficit public à hauteur
de 3% ce qu'étaient les engagements de
maastricht 3% du pib en 2027 à la fin du
quinquennat c'est ainsi que le prévoit
je disais le pacte de stabilité
budgétaire et comme le déficit s'élève
aujourd'hui à plus de 6% pour atteindre
la somme de 162 9 milliards d'euros eh
bien les insoumis ont divisé cette somme
par deux ses 2 6 à 3 et 170 par deux ça
fait 80 milliards voilà comment on est
arrivé est ce que c'est un plan caché
comme on a pu l'entendre sur les
plateaux bah non ce n'est pas un plan
caché la trajectoire des finances
publiques et c'est un document secret
c'est connu notamment des parlementaires
est-ce que c'est gravé dans le marbre là
on peut se poser la question pas
forcément non plus quand on regarde
l'histoire parce que les 3% sont un
objectif certes mais depuis la crise de
2008 la france a plus souvent été hors
des clous que dedans par ailleurs
bruxelles se montrer plus ou faut lire m
avec la crise qu vide et on s'est
peut-être avec la crise en ukraine celle
du reste si cet objectif est approché ou
tangente et comme la france ne veut pas
non plus faire n'importe quoi alors
jean-luc mélenchon il attend où il a
raison et il a raison sur l'engagement
qui a été pris le reste les conséquences
et qu il en déduit ou qu'il en tire lui
appartiennent pas ce qu il en déduit en
effet jean luc mélenchon que ça stresse
se traduira forcément de deux manières
on a entendu soit par une hausse
d'impôts spectaculaire celle de la tva
soit par un plan d'économies tout aussi
spectaculaire avec 80 milliards de
coupes budgétaires pour sa défense le
gouvernement jure ses grands dieux qu'il
n'est pas question d'augmenter les
impôts et que si les coupes sont prévues
ce seront surtout dans les dispositifs
exceptionnels qui ont été mis en place
par exemple sur le blocage face sur le
sur les blés pour contenir la hausse des
prix de l'énergie pour le reste il table
sur la croissance les créations dans moi
qui amèneront selon lui plus de
cotisations et donc plus de recettes
fiscales on a entendu les représentants
de la noblesse il rien et ironisé sur
cet effet croissance avec un petit brin
de mauvaise foi quand même et puisque
eux aussi comptent dans leur programme
quand même si j'ai bien compris sur un
effet croissance pour financer une
augmentation des dépenses publiques on a
dit de quelques 250 milliards de mots
qui figurent dans leur programme
pourquoi insister sur ce point parce que
c'est une réponse du berger à la bergère
la nuque a été la nuque mais c'était
franchement attaque est ciblée sur le
volet dépenses jugées au mieux par la
majorité est totalement irréaliste au
pire totalement impôts kalistick c'est
le venezuela son pétrole en tentant dans
la majorité et puis aussi un secret
espoir celui de rééditer le fameux coup
de la tva sociale qui avait coûté si
cher à la droite en 2007 vous souvenez
au soir du premier tour laurent fabius
avait mis en difficulté jean louis
borloo au liban dans répondait à une
question simple par oui ou par non elle
vous allez augmenter la tva ça à
l'époque c'était pour financer la baisse
du coût du travail et jean louis borloo
s'était emmêlé les pinceaux il était
mise l'économie à l'époque ça n'a duré
qu'un mois parce que ça lui a coûté son
poste et puis ça a coûté près de 50
députés alors merci de ce rappel
historique xavier timbeau ce déficit
public limité à 3% est ce que ça va
forcément devenir la règle
alors c'est une question aussi une
question qui est un peu ouverte parce
que on sort du coc vide on est en pleine
guerre même si c'est pas directement
mais il ya quand même un conflit qui
peut tout question on est aussi face à
la question la transition
environnementale et là pour le coup y'a
pas de jean luc mélenchon qui s'en est
rendu compte donc on sait qu'il ya des
dépenses qui vont être devoir fait bon
ok ça c'est une chose mais après le
pacte de stabilité on peut le prendre
comme une règle qu'on est obligé de
respecter ou avec laquelle on veut
essayer de tricher un peu mais je pense
que c'est pas en fait la bonne façon de
le regarder et c'est derrière il ya
quand même en fait l'évolution de la
dette publique
est là aussi dans les événements dans ce
qui se passe et ce qui se profile devant
nous il ya aussi d'une certaine façon
une remontée des taux d'intérêt donc
de ce point de vue là disons que il va
falloir très probablement dans les
années qui viennent stabiliser la dette
publique et stabiliser la dette publique
ça veut dire revenir avec un déficit qui
est proche de 3% donc on retrouve un peu
la logique du pacte en fait c'est pas
tout à fait la logique du pacte 1 le
pacte il ya dix ans c'était pas on doit
être à 3% c'est quand on est au-dessus
de 3% on est dans ce qu'on appelle le
bras correctif pour un déficit excessif
ou et on doit faire tous les efforts
pour revenir le plus vite possible en
dessous de 3% et ensuite faire des
efforts pour ramener son déficit à 1 05
% c'est ça le pacte avant le coup vide
avant avant la crise de 2008 donc on
n'est plus du tout dans ce monde on est
dans un monde où il ya beaucoup plus de
marge de manoeuvre mais on peut pas
rester avec un déficit à 6% parce qu'un
déficit à 6% c'est une dette qui galope
et ça pose un problème ça pose un
problème à la fois dans la construction
de la zone euro dans son équilibre ça
peut poser un problème pour les
générations futures donc voilà il ya un
moment où falloir revenir un tout petit
peu sûres
alors je reviens sur les critiques ou
les accusations emmanuel macron
sera-t-il obligé d'augmenter la tva pour
donner des gages à bruxelles eric
delannoy enfin bien sûr que non ça a été
inscrit nulle part et on sait bien que
la jouer sur la tva est toujours une
mauvaise solution parce que c'est un
impôt déguisé indifférenciée qui en
général profite à ceux qui consomment le
plus c'est donc forcément aux plus
riches donc c'est stupide au même titre
que augmenté 20 baisser la tva sur les
rives de faim dans les aliments terre
c'est aussi stupide ça profite aussi
plus aux riches que paix à ceux qui
n'ont pas les moyens donc non mais là
enfin il ya une outrance qui est qu'ils
adhérent déjà on a un problème c'est que
les 80 milliards c'est à horizon 25-20
2027 si le calcul était juste et que
donc on est effectivement sur quelque
chose qui annuellement n'est pas du tout
de 80 milliards donc quand bien même on
arriverait à tenir cette cet échéancier
moi je tiens à rappeler quand même que
dans le bilan des manuels ma compte que
tout le monde a oublié
il ya deux choses dans ce pays ultra
libérale que la nuque souvent on a
nationalisé l'économie pendant deux ans
et on est probablement lente 9,1 le pays
qui a le plus distribué d'argent pour
soutenir des entreprises et pour
soutenir les citoyens ça c'est la
première chose dont les ultras bizarre
elle s'est un peu compliqué a évoqué et
puis le deuxième sujet c'est que avant
le coc vide on avait réussi à baisser le
déficit budgétaire en dessous de 3%
rappelons 2018 on est à en dessous 3
largement ni à 2,3 on est à 3,1 en 2019
on a l'a réussi en baissant les impôts a
diminué de plus de 10 milliards par an
le déficit public donc c'est possible ça
a été fait ce n'est pas des promesses ce
n'est pas un programme ce n'est pas de
l'incantatoire ça a été fait par des
réformes donc alors il ya une chose qui
est totalement vrai par contre c'est que
l'équation se complique parce que ces
hypothèses là ont été faites dans une
hypothèse où l'on continué sur une
croissance de sortie de qu'ovide et non
pas dans un choc d'offre tel qu'on le
vit avec une demande qui a augmenté donc
une inflation forte l'inflation augmente
est aujourd'hui la croissance diminue
c'est vrai qu'on est un contest qui se
complique et donc ça va être compliqué à
tenir mais je j'ai envie de dire que en
europe on va en tenir compte les 3% et à
une réflexion autour de changer ce 3%
notamment pour différencier les
investisse je les déficits publics qui
seraient liés à des investissements pour
la transition écologique ce qui serait
une très bonne chose donc alors ça
nécessite un accord de l'ensemble des
pays c'est très compliqué mais au moins
la réflexion et dans les têtes et ça
c'est important
sabine haïtienne
jean luc mélenchon c'est quoi du déficit
public parce que il ya quand même on
peut aussi et c'est l'une des critiques
qui est fait à sont à son programme
économique penser que ce point va le
creuser le déficit public alors il faut
savoir que le programme il a été en tout
cas travailler par un serment
d'économistes dont je ne fais pas partie
mais dont de nombreux économistes
qui ont utilisé notamment des modèles de
maquereaux simulation il est largement
financier par la révolution fiscale il
est largement financée par les fonds
d'investissement qui créeront en effet
des effets induits des effets en termes
de cotisations sociales supplémentaires
en termes d'impôts sur le revenu
supplémentaire d'impôt sur le patrimoine
supplémentaire puisque l'objectif bien
sûr c'est diminuer les inégalités c'est
d'augmenter le revenu des plus modestes
et d'améliorer les services publics pour
répondre à des besoins essentiels donc
budgétaire pour aller vers les besoins
il faut partir des besoins essentiels de
la population et les besoins essentiels
de la population aujourd'hui on les a
vus notamment avec la crise sanitaire on
a vu le nombre de personnes qui
réclamaient l'aide alimentaire augmente
et on a vu va en parler du lavoir
d'acheter leur donner la parole
nationaux et du système socio fiscal par
les impôts vont augmenter non alors les
impôts vont augmenter pour une partie de
la population ils ne vont pas augmenter
pour l'essentiel de la population la
grande majorité la population ne verra
pas ses impôts notamment les impôts sur
le revenu augmenter l'impôt sur le
patrimoine seuls 10% de la population
seront concernés par cette augmentation
d'un peu chaud patrimoine donc en effet
il y un choix qui est fait il faut mieux
partager les richesses il faut mieux
partager les richesses pour mieux
répondre aux besoins essentiels de la
population et face à l'urgence
écologique mais j'aurais envie les
nouvelles générations elles ne peuvent
plus attendre elle entend complètement
cet argument pardon de interrompre fois
j'essaie de de faire en sorte que la que
le temps ne file pas trop vite mais je
vais vous poser une question on a posé
en son temps à françois hollande ben on
est riche à partir de combien par mois
parce que c'est ça la difficulté de
savate aux inégalités en effet vient de
faire une étude en disant qu'à partir de
3700 euros par personne vous faites
partie des 7 % les plus riches de france
etc ce sont des définitions statistiques
l'objectif ce n'est pas de définir sa
l'objectif c'est de montrer les
inégalités laurent willemez pardon je
pense que tous ceux qui nous regardent
se dit donc augmenter alors c'est des
gens qui gagnent qui gagnent plus de
4000 euros 5000 euros par mois qui
vireront un impôt sur le revenu
augmenter avec une augmentation la
progressivité de l'impôt l'objectif
c'est de faire en sorte que l'impôt soit
plus juste et plus équitable donc et
l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
lorsque vous faites face à un accident
de la vie et bien vous n'ayez pas peur
que vos enfants ne puissent pas faire
d'études supérieures que vous n'ayez pas
peur de vous faire soigner devoir
financer lorsque vous allez à l'hôpital
d'avoir accès à un logement décent etc
etc donc l'objectif c'est de mieux
partager les richesses de mieux partager
le temps travaille également et pour que
les besoins essentiels soient pourvus se
nourrir se loger etc etc pour que vous
fassiez face aux accidents de la vie et
même si vous gagnez plus de 5000 euros
par mois vous pouvez faire face un
accident de la vie vous retrouver au
chômage et n'oublions pas que le taux de
pauvreté chez le chômeur est de l'ordre
de 40% et que la réforme de l'assurance
chômage va être poursuivi par le
prochain par par emmanuel macron et par
si lille gagne en tout cas les élections
législatives par le prochain
gouvernement donc faisons face attention
à cela bon on va parler pouvoir d'achat
tout de suite je n'ai entendu crier pour
nous rejoindre dans une minute je vous
donne un chiffre d'abord pour commencer
source de l'insee moins 1,8 pour cent
c'est la baisse du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages au premier trimestre jonathan
effectivement c'est leur bienvenus vous
faites votre retour sur le plateau de
200 ce public avec voilà à trois jours
du second tour des propositions lanuf et
ensemble rivalisent sur ce thème du
pouvoir d'achat évidemment bah ouais le
pouvoir d'achat est toujours
l'indétrônable vous allez le voir il
reste la préoccupation première des
français
un français sur deux un quasiment le
pôle le place en double préoccupation
première devant la guerre en ukraine
devant l'environnement et surtout en ce
moment alors qu'une inflation record et
bien grève le le pouvoir d'achat de tout
le monde voilà ce que la majorité
présidentielle propose vous allez le
voir d'abord un blocage des prix de
l'énergie jusqu'à la fin de l'année à
noter aussi le maintien d'une remise de
18 centimes à la pompe pour les
carburants ça se poursuivra jusqu'à la
fin août la coalition ensemble entente
aussi créé un chèque inflation pour les
foyers les plus modestes le montant
reste à préciser mais on a vu des
estimations entre 50 et 150 euros
écoutez en tout cas la première ministre
elisabeth borne à ce sujet ce sera une
aide versée directement sur le compte en
banque tenant à une fois en une fois
tenant compte naturellement du nombre
d'enfants dans la famille et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui peut se mettre
en place à la rentrée d'accord pour
permettre à chacun de faire face à ces
augmentations que j'évoquais sur les
produits alimentaires de base voilà est
donc cette indemnité inflation elle elle
sera notamment voté dans le cadre du
projet de loi d'urgence sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui sera le premier grand projet
de loi débattu à l'assemblée après les
législatives et la première ministre
aussi lors de la même interview sur
france bleu elle avait indiqué que ce
dispositif il pourrait être complétée
ultérieurement d'un chèque alimentaire
pour aider les français à consommer bio
et local alors toujours sur ce thème du
pouvoir d'achat que propose la nuque
alors là nu peint vous allez le voir
l'union de la gauche elle a qualifié son
plan d'urgence pouvoir d'achat
d'opérations robin des bois légal la
nuque le dit vouloir surtout résorber
les inégalités la pauvreté les partis de
gauche ils veulent ainsi instauré ce
qu'ils appellent une garantie dignité
pour ne laisser personne je cite sous le
seuil de pauvreté un sas et les mots de
la coalition en résulte cette
proposition d'indemnité 1063 euros par
mois pour une personne seule qui
répondrait à ces critères la new bell
veut aussi bloquer les prix sur les
produits de première nécessité que ce
soit l'alimentation
pourquoi pas bloquer l'envolée des prix
du pétrole est d'ailleurs jean-luc
mélenchon à toulouse et bien il reproché
manuel macron lui de ne rien faire un
sujet
puisque nous sommes en europe
450 millions de consommateurs qu'attend
le président l'union européenne un
certain emmanuel macron
qu'est-ce qu'il a tort pour proposer au
nom de la france
le blocage du prix du pétrole qui est la
seule manière de pouffer la contagion
voilà est à noter aussi que la gauche
veut immédiatement revaloriser le
salaire minimum y porter le smic à 1500
euros nets mensuels et mathieu vous le
rappeliez mais c'est vrai que la nuque a
été particulièrement critiqué au moment
de la sortie de ce programme économique
au sens large un pas seulement sur les
mesures pouvoir d'achat qu'elle chiffre
à 250 milliards par an tout compris
voilà ce chiffre beaucoup j'ai attendu
prière xavier timbeau
peut-être si on peut commencer sur le
bouclier tarifaire des mamelles magron
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ça coûte cher ça coûte très cher
c'est relativement efficace parce que
quand on compare l'inflation en france à
d'autres pays européens un meilleur
résultat
ça coûte très cher ça c'est difficile à
maintenir par ailleurs c'est assez à 2 2
gros inconvénient le premier c'est que
c'est pas du tout ciblées et donc ça
profite autant à celui qui va mettre de
l'essence dans sa voiture de luxe alors
là pas besoin et qui n'a pas d'odeur
ailleurs
et puis ça aussi
enlève alors certes en fait c'est même
encore plus que ça mais ça ça brise ce
qu'on appelle le signal prix évoqué jean
tirole tout à l'heure le signal prix et
qui doit nous pousser à la transition
environnementale en expliquant que les
fossiles bah oui c'est cher et donc donc
en fait si vous venez ça ne ça ne
rétablit pas l' équilibre entre le prix
d'utilisation d'une voiture électrique
par rapport à une voiture facile ou
l'utilisation du train par rapport à
prendre sa voiture
ça crée même en fait autre chose qu'une
forme de précédent qui va en fait laissé
passer la croyance que le rôle du
gouvernement c'est de nous préserver de
ces augmentations est donc en quelque
sorte de nous de nous séparer de nous
anesthésier de cette réalité l'économie
réelle quoi de l'économie réelle est
aussi de cette impérieuse nécessité
qu'on a de se passer des fossiles donc
voilà on peut alors c'est pas ceci étant
dit la critique on peut la faire sur le
sur le programmes des manuels macron
mais en fait on la retrouve exactement
dans le programme de la nuque ce canton
quand on dit qu'on va mais chris ans à 1
0 40
c'est quelque chose qui est à la fois
pas ciblé qu'on retombe dans la même
critique et en même temps c'est aussi
quelque chose qui nous
ce qui va même encore plus loin dans
arrête de monter les prix de l'essence
et donc continuer à utiliser votre
voiture bon voilà on est un peu face à
ce problème là juste pour rebondir sur
un des propos de jean luc mélenchon je
pense bon pour le prix du pétrole je
pense que c'est pas assez pas réaliste
et raisonnable alors bloquer les prix du
pétrole n'ont sais pas pourquoi c'est
pas réaliste et raisonnable c'est parce
que même si l'europe est un grand pays
en fait les producteurs de pétrole
défendre leurs intérêts et probablement
la stratégie des états unis qui est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que l'arabie
saoudite reproduise plus et une
stratégie qui est plus raisonnable sur
le plan du pétrole mais par contre on a
quand même la question du gaz le gaz on
l'achète à la russie on est en guerre
avec la russie la russie a encaissé sur
les 100 premiers jours du conflit plus
de 100 milliards de dollars de recettes
liées à la fois au pétrole et au gaz et
là pour le coup quand il ya un conflit
et qu'on opère des sanctions sur ce pays
on pourrait dire le prix auquel on veut
acheter le gaz on va le fixer à 40 euros
ou à 50 euros le mégawattheure au lieu
de le payer le prix que l'on paye parce
que ça fait partie des mesures de
rétorsion et si la russie ne veut plus
vendre son gaz à l'europe soit qu'elles
ne le vendent plus mais on sait que à
court terme et ne le pourra pas le vent
à quelqu'un d'autre donc voilà il ya il
ya un jeu a menés là dessus sur les gaz
très largement qui n'a pas été qui n'a
pas été envisagé je retiens un élément
dans votre cuisine je reste sur le le
bouclier tarifaire ou les mesures qui
ont été annoncées globalement par
emmanuel macron puis par elisabeth bande
est-ce qu'il faut pas quand même
effectivement les ciblées vers les
français les plus pauvres parce que
c'est pas le défaut de la cuirasse ça
quand même rigolo il faut bien
évidemment les cibles et fin d'où la
notion de chaque alimentaire
ou le chèque nrj12 enfin oui pourquoi il
faut les cibles il faut les cibles et
parce que on sert pas été fait jusqu'à
présent les amants bat pas suffisamment
mais en même temps je sais pas si dans
une inflation qui égale le prendre comme
aujourd'hui il y a quelque chose de
suffisant la seule chose qui est
certaine c'est que aujourd'hui il faut
qu il faut qu on suffoque on s'occupe
des 20% des personnes qui gagnent le
moins parce que réduire les inégalités
faut rappeler que sur les unités de
revenus la france est le mieux disant en
europe quand même il faut le rappeler
avec la redistribution qui est
considérable en france et qui est très
bien c'est une politique de
redistribution qui est très important on
passe de 20 à 22 ans mais parmi les
moins les lits % les moins riches les
10% les plus riches à 1,8 après
redistribution donc jusqu'où faut-il
aller à 2 1 3 c'est un débat qui est à
tu reviens vers le sujet autour des
patrimoines en revanche qu'il faudra
regarder et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve dans le programme de lannux
néanmoins sur la partie pouvoir d'achat
il faut cibler sur les sur ceux qui ont
des vraies difficultés parce qu'il faut
pas se la raconter le pays la france va
bien c'est pas parce qu'on a une
inflation à 5 % que tout à coup tu
personne ne peut se nourrir alors
aujourd'hui avec ce que l'on entend dans
les outrances quand on est optimiste on
est riche on ne peut plus être au pays
des miss en france regardez ce qui s'est
passé lors des embouteillages de
l'ascension regarder les réservations
qui s'en fait pour les vacances la
france va bien il y à une partie de la
population qui va pas bien celle là
effectivement faut cibler pour les aider
le problème qui se pose c'est que si on
fait de manière générale on rentre dans
une dynamique de prix de bouc ce qu'on
appelle la boucle prix salaires ça veut
dire qu'en fait on va distribuer de
l'argent et donc si on distribue de
l'argent on augmente les salaires on
augmente les prix parce que les
entreprises ont répercuté de ça sur les
prix dans un couple dans une
problématique ou c'est pas le sujet on a
déjà un décalage de demandes et offres
on a un problème sur le choc de l'offre
on ne peut pas distribuer de l'argent à
tout le monde ce n'est pas possible
balieux voilà je vous interromps je sais
mieux vous avez encore plein de choses à
dire mais je voudrais donner la parole à
sabinas iseman peut-être sur
effectivement le la hausse des salaires
et de l'analyser attention à la boucle
inflationnistes or c'est l'une des
propositions de la nuque ces deux voilà
de d'engager deux grandes négociations
salariales alors on n'est pas du tout
dans la situation de la fin des années
70 là on a des salaires qui augmentent
moins que l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat
diminué il faut rappeler en effet que on
a deux millions de salariés qui
travaille au smic ce sont des femmes des
femmes aussi qui travaillent à temps
partiel qui vivait avec un demi smic on
a 50 % des salariés qui vivent avec
moins d'un véhicule sismique donc en
effet cette france là peut-être que vous
ne la voyez pas mais moi je la vois je
vois mes étudiants arrêtés de venir en
cours parce que et ils ont été obligés
de prendre un travail alimentaire en
plus donc cette cette france là elle
existe elle existe peut-être pas à côté
de chez vous mais elle existe en tout
cas au sein de mes étudiants elles
existent dans les quartiers où nous
vivons en tout cas nous la voyons
statistiquement parlant également est
cette france là elle a besoin de huit
jours une augmentation pouvoir d'achat
une augmentation de pouvoir d'achat pas
seulement en termes de prestations
sociales et de service public il en faut
mais également en termes de
revalorisations salariales et de
traitement des fonctionnaires puisque
maintenant on n'oublie pas qu'à côté des
salariés du privé qui ont besoin d'une
revalorisation et on n'oublie pas que
vous n'avez pas permis d'augmentation
coup de pouce du smic sous le
quinquennat macron vous l'avez augmentée
vous l'avez augmenté deux fois oui vous
l'avez augmenté mais pas partout peut
pas vous avez vous n'avez pas de donner
une tendance pour cent quand j'en avais
su à l'époque je ne vais pas vous n'avez
pas vous n'avez pas permis une
augmentation qui puisse permite qui
puisse permettre ce rattrapage en tout
cas pour la salle pour les salariés au
salaire minimum
aujourd'hui en termes de traitement des
fonctionnaires vous avez un gel du point
d'indicé depuis dix ans sauf les deux
petites augmentations 2016 de 0,6 pour
cent l'étonnante vous avait une perte de
pouvoir d'achat au sein des
fonctionnaires dont les catégories c ont
particulièrement pâti et donc vous avez
aujourd'hui d'élus 2022 une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat
et
des difficultés pour un certain nombre
de travailleurs d'inactifs d'actifs
inoccupé de chômeurs de pouvoir se
nourrir et de pouvoir accéder à une
nourriture abordables et de qualité et
aujourd'hui c'est le cas mais voilà
circuit les de pouvoir aller au travail
etc et donc en effet cesser ces mesures
de blocage ce sont des mesures en effet
qui vise qui doivent s'accompagner sur
le moyen terme par exemple de plein de
transports publics gratuits parce que
quand voudrait qu'un euro car on est au
départ dont une grand quand j'essaie il
a aussi injecté j'ai interrompu avec
deux lamas tout à l'heure mais encore je
reviens sur ce ce prix il ya aujourd'hui
des millions il ya même je crois huit
français sur dix comparent d'autre choix
que d'utiliser leur voiture et parmi eux
ils sont très nombreux à rouler en
diesel et un chiffre c'est que dans les
ventes de voitures d'occasion on achète
plus de diesel que que d'autres donc
voyez ce que je veux dire comment vont
faire les français qui roulent en diesel
qu'on pas d'autre choix avec un fer avec
à ittre 48,6 en transition sociale je
suis d'accord sans maintien du pouvoir
d'achat et sans hausse du pouvoir
d'achat et notamment pour les blés donc
il faut les signes faujas ciblées et
c'est possible alors il faut les cibles
et mais pas seulement de cibler il faut
également faire en sorte de d'améliorer
le service public et d'améliorer les
transports si on ne donne pas à fait
relative aux personnes ça prend ça prend
du temps mais on peut mettre en place
des des politiques de grands travaux et
c'est l'objectif des 200 milliards de
deux programmes en tout cas qu'il est
proposé divise a véritablement avoir une
transition en tout cas
écologique 1 ou de réponse rapide en une
minute il ya des choses qui ont été
faites les maisons france services dont
plus de 200000 que de 2000 communes qui
vont êtres qui sont une vraie réponse à
l'électro nisme local allait décerner
désertification des services publics il
ya des choses qui ont été faites en a
mis fin aux zones blanches qui était
endémique avant 2017 faille on peut pas
dire que rien n'a été fait c'est
vraiment il ya quelque chose de très
outrance il annonce donc en revanche
effectivement faut aider les salaires
les plus les plus faibles c'est ça c'est
bien évident parce que ce que je
voudrais évoquer quand même c'est que on
oublie souvent qu'il ya eu 175 milliards
de dhs épargne supplémentaire qui a été
permise permise malheureusement par le
par le confinement il est vrai que c'est
pas les 20% les plus forts mais c'est
75% de la population qui a épargné 75%
de la population épargné on peut me
raconter ce qu'on veut ce sont les
chiffres de l'insee alors il est vrai
que les 25% la population à épargner
plus de 10000 euros et les 25% de la
population l'appeler les moins riches
n'ont rien épargné mais 75% de la
population à épargner il faut utiliser
les parent ni bon on terminera là dessus
tout le monde a eu la parole merci
beaucoup encore une fois de ce débat